Si os parece, comencemos con una pregunta curiosa:
¿alguno sabría decirme cuántas elecciones se van a
celebrar este año 2024 en todo el mundo?
Hablamos de elecciones tanto generales,
como regionales y municipales. ¿Alguna ida? Pues
hablamos, ni más ni menos que, de 76 elecciones.
Los comicios en la India, Pakistán,
Rusia, México, Brasil y las elecciones
al Parlamento Europeo llamarán a votar
a la mitad de toda la población mundial.
Sin embargo, creo que si en algo todos
vamos a estar de acuerdo es en que hay
unas elecciones que destacan por encima
de todas las semanas: por supuesto,
estoy hablando, como no, de las elecciones
presidenciales de los Estados Unidos de América.
Unas elecciones que podrían terminar con el
regreso de Donald Trump a la Casa Blanca.
Hoy por hoy no es lo más probable, pero
podría llegar a ocurrir. La inflación
y sobre todo la edad le están pasando
factura a la popularidad de Joe Biden.
De hecho, según una reciente encuesta
del Washington Post, el 63% de los
estadounidenses no creen que Biden esté en
condiciones de afrontar un segundo mandato.
Pero, queridos amigos, en esta ocasión no
os vamos a hablar del presidente Biden.
Hoy los focos los ponemos ni más ni menos que
en la figura que le acompañó hasta la victoria:
la vicepresidenta Kamala Harris.
Porque si pensáis que la popularidad
de Biden es baja, eso es porque
no habéis visto la de Harris. En
especial por noticias como estas:
N1 (Kamala Harris, la increíble
vicepresidenta que desaparece. LATimes)
La vicepresidenta más desconocida que
podamos recordar se ha convertido
en un motivo de seria preocupación
dentro de la cúpula del Partido Demócrata.
Lo es por una simple razón: necesitan que todo
sea o, al menos, aparente ser perfecto para
impedir que Trump regrese al Despacho Oval.
Y, aquí, es donde juega un papel especialmente
importante la vicepresidenta Kamala Harris.
Pero ¿por qué? ¿No se supone acaso que el papel
principal es el del candidato presidencial,
Joe Biden? ¿Por qué muchos consideran ya a Harris
la clave para una nueva victoria demócrata?
Aviso: si muchos no conocéis a Kamala Harris
no os culpo, lleva tiempo que parece más un
fantasma que una vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos.
Pero amigos, con este vídeo eso va a cambiar.
¡Arranquemos!
T1 (KAMALA, ROMPIENDO BARRERAS)
Kamala Harris es una de esas personas
cuyo perfil parece predestinado
para la gran política de Washington:
Hija de una investigadora india contra
el cáncer y de un economista jamaicano,
comenzó a romper barreras muy pronto.
Ya en 1990 empezó a trabajar en la
oficina del fiscal del distrito de
San Francisco después de graduarse en
derecho en la Universidad de California.
Durante los 8 años que estuvo en aquella oficina,
Kamala comenzó a labrarse una reputación de “mujer
dura”. Su trabajo por aquel entonces se centró
en la lucha contra la violencia de bandas,
el tráfico de drogas y el abuso sexual a menores.
Sin embargo, aquello tan solo sería el principio
de una carrera extremadamente fructífera.
Y es que veréis, habiendo conseguido cierta
reputación en la ciudad de San Francisco, en
2004 se convirtió en la fiscal del distrito.
En este tiempo, su fama de “mujer
dura” se vio incrementada después de
que la tasa de condenas en el distrito se
disparara durante sus tres primeros años.
Quizás por eso, en 2010, logró ser elegida
como fiscal general del Estado de California,
la primera mujer y la primera persona
afroamericana en ocupar ese puesto.
Pues bien, fue justo en esta etapa cuando
consiguió una gran notoriedad a nivel nacional,
especialmente gracias a convertirse en una de las
principales voces en contra de la Proposición 8,
que prohibía los matrimonios homosexuales.
Y, no solo eso, en 2012 consiguió uno de
sus mayores logros: un acuerdo de $20.000
millones para los californianos cuyas viviendas
habían sido embargadas tras ser víctimas de
prácticas consideradas injustas por parte de
prestamistas hipotecarios antes del año 2007.
Así que, claro, después de semejante victoria,
su nombre empezó a crecer como la
espuma dentro del Partido Demócrata.
Y, finalmente, en 2016, centrándose
en asuntos como el aborto,
el aumento del salario mínimo o
la reforma del sistema judicial,
se convirtió en senadora por el estado
más poblado de Estados Unidos: California.
Fue la primera mujer indio-americana y la
segunda mujer negra en la historia del Senado.
Y amigo, fue en esta cámara cuando Kamala Harris
dio el salto definitivo en el mundo de la gran
política. Lo hizo haciendo a sus oponentes
en las audiencias preguntas muy incisivas:
inglés al español decídmelo sin problema).
Por supuesto, con una popularidad en ascenso,
sus aspiraciones políticas no se limitarían
al Senado. Y en 2019 anunció su campaña para
conseguir hacerse con la nominación del Partido
Demócrata en las presidenciales de 2020. Harris
quería convertirse en la rival de Trump. Sin
embargo, la falta de financiación y una serie
de errores cometidos durante la campaña, hizo
que su estrella, que empezó pisando fuerte en
las primarias, acabara apagándose.
Sin embargo, Joe Biden, tras ser
nombrado candidato demócrata y quizás tras
el conflicto y la tensión producida con el
asesinato de George Floyd tomo esta decisión:
N2 (La vicepresidenta elegida por Joe Biden:
Kamala Harris. NYTimes)
Y, así, finalmente,
tras la derrota de Trump en 2020, el 20 de enero
de 2021, Harris se convirtió en la primera mujer,
afroamericana y de origen indio, en ocupar
la posición de vicepresidenta de los Estados
Unidos. En aquel momento, muchos la
veían como la clara heredera de Biden.
Sin embargo, estos últimos 3 años han supuesto
todo un frenazo para la carrera estelar de
Harris, tan desaparecida que hoy muchos se
preguntan ¿quién demonios es Kamala Harris?
Así que la pregunta es, ¿qué diantres ha
pasado? Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (HARRIS, EN DECADENCIA)
Seamos justos, son pocos los casos en los
que se recuerda a los vicepresidentes de
Estados Unidos. Pocos, muy pocos, han logrado
ser recordados al cabo de unos cuantos años.
Sin embargo, con Kamala Harris se había generado
la expectativa de que esto no fuera así:
Se esperaba un giro de 180º en
la vicepresidencia. Se pensaba
que tendría un gran peso dentro del gobierno.
Pero, por desgracia para ella, eso no ha sido
así. Harris llegó a Washington pensando en ser
la nueva Dick Cheney moviendo hilos a su antojo
y terminó siendo más bien… Selina Meyer – si no
habéis visto Veep, no sé a qué estáis esperando
A diferencia de algunos exvicepresidentes
demócratas como Al Gore con Bill Clinton o Joe
Biden con Barack Obama, o incluso el republicano
Dick Cheney con Bush hijo, que lograron tener
bastante influencia en el ejecutivo, Harris no
ha sido capaz de lograr tener su propia voz.
Eso sí, muchos analistas defienden que Harris ha
cumplido estrictamente con lo que normalmente se
espera de un vicepresidente: que no es otra
cosa que no hacerle sombra a su presidente.
Tradicionalmente, el puesto de “Vice” no ha
sido ni el más brillante ni un gran trampolín.
De hecho, en los últimos 50 años solo dos
vicepresidentes luego fueron elegidos presidentes:
George Bush, padre y el propio
Joe Biden. – Bueno, y Gerald Ford,
que llegó al despacho oval de rebote.
Así que para muchos la “ausencia” no
resulta tan extraña… Sino algo bastante normal.
Bajo esta perspectiva Kamala podría haber
cumplido con lo que se espera del puesto.
De hecho, pese a esa aparente ausencia,
Harris ha sido clave para la administración
Biden en repetidas ocasiones, especialmente
en el Senado, donde ha roto bastantes empates.
N3 (5 de diciembre de 2023: Kamala Harris bate
el récord de votos de desempate en el Senado
La vicepresidenta ha aportado el voto decisivo
en el Senado en 32 ocasiones, en un reflejo
de la estrecha mayoría demócrata y de la
polarización más amplia de la política. NYTimes)
De hecho, su voto de desempate fue absolutamente
decisivo para sacar adelante una de las
principales medidas de la administración Biden:
el plan de estímulo económico tras
la pandemia de 2 billones de dólares.
Además, también ha logrado que todos
los candidatos del presidente Biden
sean confirmados tanto en el Congreso como
en el Senado, algo que ha resultado clave
para hacer avanzar la agenda del gobierno.
Y, por si fuera poco, Harris ha jugado un
papel más importante del que nos
podría parecer a primera vista en
la política exterior de la Casa Blanca.
Por ejemplo, en estos 3 años ha visitado
casi 20 países y se ha reunido con más de
100 líderes mundiales. De hecho, Harris no
solo fue clave para normalizar las relaciones
diplomáticas con Francia en 2021, sino también
fue quien a principios de 2022 avisó al propio
Zelensky de la inminente invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Sin embargo, toda esta actividad se ha quedado
en nada en comparación con la percepción pública
de estar desaparecida y con el aluvión de
críticas que ha recibido desde su nombramiento.
Y para muchos este mal desempeño “político”
ha tenido mucho que ver con su ambición.
Por ejemplo, tan solo 6 meses después de asumir
la vicepresidencia, se la criticó por no haber
querido visitar directamente la frontera
sur para impulsar medidas que aliviaran
la crisis migratoria. Digamos que Kamala
Harris no quería mancharse con esos temas.
Luego, tras su sonoro fracaso en la entrevista
con el periodista Lester Holt, de la NBC,
para explicar la situación, la
confianza en ella se desplomó.
Para noviembre de 2021, su índice de aprobación
se situó tan solo en un 28%, convirtiéndose así
en una de las vicepresidencias
más impopulares de la historia.
Además, a Harris también le han perseguido ciertas
acusaciones por supuestamente crear en torno a
ella un ambiente laboral extremadamente tóxico,
rozando casos de acoso. Y muchos ligan esta
situación a la renuncia de piezas claves en su
equipo durante el primer año y medio de mandato.
Por si fuera poco, Harris ha protagonizado
algunos momentos especialmente embarazosos
en actos públicos, donde las frases con poco
sentido se han llegado a hacer virales, lo que,
por supuesto, la oposición ha explotado
con el fin de ridiculizar su figura.
Y todo esto explica por qué la
aprobación de Harris a lo largo
de 2023 se situó tan solo en el 32%.
Sin embargo, en los últimos meses su
equipo y ella misma se han propuesto
un objetivo: relanzar su imagen ante un
factor clave en estas elecciones de 2024:
La avanzada edad del presidente Biden.
Atentos.
T3 (¿LA CLAVE DEMÓCRATA?)
A finales del mes de abril de
2023, Biden anunció finalmente
su decisión de presentarse a la reelección.
Junto a él, como era de esperar, se mantendría
Kamala Harris. El problema es que si esto se
produce, la campaña electoral estará dominada
por un tema muy concreto: la edad de Joe Biden.
Y es que, veréis, de ser reelegido, Biden
se convertiría en el presidente electo más
anciano de la historia del país con 82 años.
Así que muchos ya dudan de la capacidad real del
actual presidente de completar un segundo mandato
que teóricamente terminaría con la friolera
de 86 años. Precisamente, por eso, todos los
focos están esta vez fijados en Kamala Harris.
De hecho, desde el Partido Republicano ya lo
dicen alto y claro: un voto para el presidente
Biden es un voto para la presidenta Harris.
Y esa es exactamente la misma razón por la
que Harris y su equipo llevan trabajando
intensamente en los últimos meses para intentar
mejorar la percepción pública de una de las
vicepresidencias más impopulares de la historia.
Claro que no es algo estrictamente nuevo.
Fue ya en junio de 2022 cuando Harris vio
la oportunidad de volver a relanzar su
imagen tras la derogación de la doctrina Roe
contra Wade por parte del Tribunal Supremo,
lo que provocó la eliminación del derecho
al aborto que el propio Tribunal había
sostenido durante los 50 últimos años.
Pues bien, la Vicepresidenta se convirtió
en una de las principales voces contra esta
decisión y acabó siendo crucial a la hora de
explotar este caso en favor de los demócratas.
Eso mejoró su imagen, pero no fue suficiente.
Por eso, en el último año, ha estado realizando
un tour por diferentes universidades del país
para afianzar el voto joven con una agenda
centrada en asuntos como el propio aborto,
el medio ambiente o los derechos LGBT.
Al mismo tiempo, Harris ha ido elevando
de nuevo su faceta más combativa. Y lo
cierto es que los datos parecen decir que
el plan está funcionando: su imagen dentro
del Partido Demócrata ha mejorado y muchos
lobbies parecen volver a apostar por ella.
N4 (11 de junio de 2023: Harris recibe su
caballería: Los principales grupos gastarán más de
10 millones de dólares para apoyarla. Politico)
N5 (19 de septiembre de 2023: Harris es "sin duda"
la mejor opción para Biden: Newsom. The Hillon)
Además, no es solo que Harris esté mejorando
su imagen, sino que esta vez la
historia puede estar de su parte
si los republicanos insisten en atacarla.
Con todo, Harris no puede cantar victoria tan
fácilmente. Pese a todos los esfuerzos realizados,
su nivel de popularidad sigue por los suelos.
Y para colmo la vicepresidente
arrastra una profunda mancha:
la crisis migratoria en la frontera con México.
Y es que, veréis, desde la llegada de Biden y
Harris a la Casa Blanca en 2021, el número de
encuentros con inmigrantes en la frontera con
México ha estado creciendo exponencialmente hasta
superar los niveles récord de hace más de 20 años.
De hecho, tan solo entre octubre y
diciembre de 2023, 730.000 migrantes
fueron detenidos justo en la frontera con México.
Y, desde luego, noticias como esta nos indican
que la presión parece ir solamente en aumento:
N6 (Dic. 26, 2023: La caravana masiva de migrantes
que se dirige a la frontera entre EE.UU. y México
es la más grande en más de un año, puede llegar a
15 mil personas, advierte activista. NYPost)
Desde la oficina de la vicepresidenta,
que ha sido, precisamente, la responsable de la
política migratoria en la Administración Biden,
se ha intentado hacer frente a esta crisis,
centrándose en la mayor fuente de esta migración
masiva: el denominado “Triángulo Norte”.
(El “Triángulo Norte” se refiere al espacio
conformado por Guatemala, Honduras y
El Salvador. Ya os hemos contado aquí,
en VisualPolitik, en varias ocasiones las duras
condiciones de vida que existen en estos países:
pobreza, inseguridad, corrupción… No es
de extrañar que sea una de las principales
fuentes de emigrantes hacia Estados Unidos.)
Pues bien, la vicepresidenta Harris ha impulsado
la denominada “Estrategia de EE.UU. para
abordar las causas principales de la migración
centroamericana”. Una estrategia dotada con 4.200
millones de dólares tanto públicos como privados,
con la que se busca mejorar las
condiciones de vida de estos tres
países para desincentivar así la emigración.
Junto a ello, desde la administración Biden
también se han celebrado varias reuniones
con el presidente mexicano, AMLO, para
involucrar más a este país y se ha reforzado
la financiación de la seguridad fronteriza.
Sin embargo, parece evidente que estas medidas,
por el momento, no están surtiendo ningún efecto.
Entre otras cosas porque cambiar la realidad
socioeconómica de varios países es un proceso
de muchos años, y porque tampoco es que la
ejecución del plan parezca haber sido la mejor.
Además, los estadounidenses quieren resultados
rápidos ante lo que se ha convertido ni más ni
menos que en una de sus mayores preocupaciones:
Esta crisis migratoria junto con la crisis de la
inflación son, con mucho diferencia, las dos
grandes bazas para las aspiraciones de Donald
Trump de hacerse con la Casa Blanca. Y son en
gran medida lo que explica noticias como estas:
N7 (Trump lidera en 5 estados críticos
mientras los votantes critican a Biden,
según una encuesta de Times/Siena. NYTimes)
N8 (Golpe a Biden: un sondeo da ventaja a Trump
para las presidenciales de 2024.
Trump aventaja por 47% a 43%,
lo que preocupa a algunos demócratas mientras
otros advierten que hay que evitar la "enfermedad
loca de las encuestas". The Guardian)
Así que ya lo veis, Kamala Harris,
la vicepresidenta que llegó rompiendo todas
las barreras puede llegar a jugar un papel
clave en la reelección. Tiene la juventud y la
energía potencial que quizás le falte a Biden.
Después de un difícil comienzo y la debacle
de su imagen política, Harris quiere recuperar
terreno para lograr hacerse con el objetivo
más codiciado por todos los políticos de
Washington: el Despacho Oval.
Pero, llegados a este punto,
el turno ahora es para todos vosotros:
¿Creéis que Harris es la verdadera clave
para la reelección demócrata? ¿Cómo puede hacer
frente esta Administración a la grave crisis
migratoria en la frontera sur? ¿Será esta crisis
la que aúpe nuevamente a Trump a la presidencia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis que
aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribíos a este
canal y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha
gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.